[Musique]
est possible que si mon père n'était pas
mort je ne serais pas resté sur la
famille je suis né ici j'ai 35 ans et ça
fait 14 ans que nous sommes mariés et
que avons pris la ferme pour l'autre
compte il ya quatre générations
ma grand-mère la génération de ma main
nous mêmes et nos enfants
maintenant avec la machine est avec
serait mieux qu'ils se fait plus
agréablement et partir de l'amélioration
de nos conditions de travail surtout
pour une femme
j'ai la responsabilité de la traite et
alors je ne m'occupe pas c'est mon mari
est là aussi les pales à hâter leur jeu
très tous les matins c'est maman qui
assurent le déjeuner des enfants est
alors moi je peux dans la forme libérer
pour assurer la traite un tract du matin
sinon pour avoir terminé à 8 heures
retraite il faudrait que je commence en
moins à 6h30 bien maintenant elle se met
s'est marié en 1930 je crois oui ça fait
trente six ans qu'elle est sur la ferme
envoyé beaucoup de femmes qui qui l'a
bruit avec une paire de boeufs et la
charrue et qui retournait la charrue
lorsque vous arrivez mou du champ et qui
repartaient jeunes et marylène
[Musique]
allez au revoir à deux soirées chercher
le hameau de nas thiès est à un
kilomètre environ de la ferme les deux
valses à la même heure
juliette couderc il commence sa journée
depuis la récente division du travail
entre les deux familles elle n'a plus à
s'occuper de traite pour l'association
elle est responsable de l'élevage des
veaux bien avant l'association
il y avait toujours eu l'entr'aide
pratiqué par tous au hameau et dans les
environs mais d'année en année elle a
été rendue plus difficile par l'exode
des habitants
d'autre part il devenait chaque jour
plus évident pour les deux familles que
l'entr'aide à elle seule ne pouvait tout
résoudre
pourtant on travaille encore en commun
pendant les moissons ou les travaux
d'automne avec les plus proches voisins
restants c'est une manière d'affirmer
que la toute jeune association ne veut
pas se refermer sur elle-même
l'association on en parle beaucoup
alentours moi vous savez non question
d'association longs mois jeudi dans un
village où c'est de bien comme ça se
passe chez nous on n'a pas besoin
d'associations
parce que avec les machines qu'on a on
peut s'aider
si on n'a pas cette machine l'autre là
alors on se dit prête on travaille
ensemble et ça va je ne sais pas non je
crois pas pas des moindres aux mains
parce que je trouve que quand même on
n'a pas une vie de famille à ces assises
est dépendante quoi par le fait on a
toujours l'autre associé qui est là qui
voit ce qui se passe chez vous on fait
ou que sais-je encore semer part entre
la nuit en place pour résoudre
qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait je te prie
mais c'est peut-être parce qu'on est à
paris lorsqu'on ne suis pas le progrès
au rythme web apps peut-être les gens
sont contre l'association précise parce
qu'on a toujours été habitué à se
débrouiller tout seul acheté chacun ne
sont pas triés tout seul et alors on ne
voit pas l'utilité de ce de se grouper
et c'est dommage parce que je crois que
dans les régions où les prix se sont
beaucoup plus importantes qu'ici les
gens s'unissent eux et si vous faisiez
ses plantations ainsi si on continue à
ce chat loose et les uns les autres mais
on ne peut que creuser ça veut dire
c'est impossible de s'en sortir
je vois comme ça et je pense que ça va
nous libérer les femmes
il travaille deschamps nous pourrons
ainsi faire moins de moins de culture
afin de nous sommes prêts sur l'élevage
est en nous faisant moins de culture
nous aurons moins de travail dans les
champs
je ne veux pas dire qu'en période de
travaux ici encore on avait la culture
de pommes de terre on est bien occupée
et même que notre association n'est
encore tout jeune en marche que depuis
deux mois on a beaucoup d'aménagements
fernand beaucoup d'améliorations affaire
qui qui font encore on est quelquefois
handicapés même veine je crois que
l'association devait devrait nous
apporter cette libération du travail
avoir une avoir un travail à faire mater
histoire régulièrement une heure une
heure et demie de travail à faire pour
le compte de l'exploitation et après
avoir le reste du temps pour nous femmes
personnellement pour notre intérieur
pour nos enfants pour l'autre jardin par
exemple pour le pendant de loisirs la
culture des fleurs ou le faire nos
courses en ville que c'est je crois je
ne pense pas que cette association
démolisseurs vie de famille je crois
qu'on passera davantage de temps avec
eux
j'ai lu des livres nous éliminons la
campagne pour finalité la nature
l'inventaire
il faut alors du virus
maintenant il ya des progrès mais au
lieu de 4 heures et on travaille le plus
long avec moins de rendement non
pourrait passer aujourd'hui on va passer
campagne échanges deviennent jour là
mais maintenant vite assez vite assez
vite avec quelques pas assez vite
et pourquoi ne peuvent-ils pas l'avouer
ainsi qu'une foule mais c'est à dire que
les hommes au combat mené la campagne il
faut toujours du matériel haricots verts
jeu toujours acheter quelque chose alors
les hommes passent à 20 et ça passe
après c'est à dire il n'y a pas assez
d'argent et pas assez d'argent voilà
tout en travaillant beaucoup on n'a pas
assez d'argent
comment on fait toujours passer ce qui
sera rentable soit les étables les
aménagements de porcherie et est alors
la maison qu'ils ont toujours nourri
yeux c'est ce que nous avons fait il ya
un projet pour aménager la maison mais
c'est venu après la porcherie et après
les tables ça s'explique un peu parce
que les bêtes c'est ce qui nous rapporte
et la maison on ne s'est agréablement et
ça rapporte pas d'argent on voit les
choses comme ça d'une façon pratique de
quoi on a bien fait comme tout le monde
va bien commencer à penser au matériel
et
les valorisations de l'exploitation on
savait quand même 14 ans que nous sommes
de l'exploitation et on va me trouver
l'année pour mettre sous la maison
mais vous savez on a tous eu humaine
on va d'abord améliorer ses conditions
de travail avant d'améliorer ses
conditions de vie est-ce que c'est
logique ou quoi souvent c'est pas ce
problème important moi je dis oui 90
quand mon mari a acheté un tracteur
pourtant n'avaient rien à la maison mais
pas de machine à laver j'avais rien fait
j'étais l'événement car j'étais par
terre je t'ai bien libéré des tâches
respectives
il avait du matériel en double tous les
deux ils ont deux vendu les parts de ce
mois respectives et ils ont acheté un
semoir adapté aux tracteurs avec prise
de force de plus moderne et une seule
personne c'est le blé alors qu'avant il
fallait quelques fois j'ai dit à mon
mari
claudine la fille aînée est au lycée de
villefranche de rouergue en fin de
semaine elle rejoint sa famille l'an
dernier sur une tradition celle toutes
les semaines au premier trimestre je
parte et que tous les quelques jours je
me suis ni bhl premier cas ce jour et
coloré car je partais de 15 jours la
qualifiée par télé ça me dit rien allez
on peut alors elle dit commence à celle
là ça pélissanne moi j'ai pas répondu
j'ai dit je te dis parents fait bien
fait l a pas entendu mais le ciel avant
tenue moi ça me fait plaisir d'aller
impressions je rêvais que tout s'arrête
qu'au neuvième position j'étais
légèrement que je n'irai pas enfin que
ce truc contente elle m'a dit tu verras
tu as bien j'avais le café quand je
voyais les ans qui partait le samedi
vous
j'ai dit elle partait moi je vous laisse
vous faire votre avis les allait devenir
tous les soirs à la maison
il s'éloigne de le noyer ils sont lancés
dans la vie pour ainsi dire quoi mais
pas dans les mêmes que les vôtres
ab non pas du tout parce que mon dieu
moi je vois les nécros albet sur
certaines choses il ne vais pas fouiller
maintenance c'est pas du tout le même
genre de levier évidemment ça les
couples même énormément parce que on
voit les on les voit comme qu'ils ont
passés en amont et mes deux amis ou 3-1
pensières ce n'est plus du tout les
mêmes les mains
lens ne reconnaît plus non les revend
les primes h le matin qu'on assiste à la
messe et que rencontre des gens aussi
las on peut dire que c'était jour de
distraction c'est une vieille coutume
qui veut que les femmes sont d'un côté
les hommes de l'autre
je ne sais pas pourquoi on essayait bien
de
faire changer les mentalités mais mais
c'est difficile de rompre avec les
habitudes du passé
commentaire de se faire remarquer c'est
très important pour l'instant moi je
crois parce que s'ils ont des affaires à
discuter entre eux s'ils veulent voir
par exemple ce que je vois un tel projet
demandé si c'était la machine est libre
s'ils peuvent venir m'aider à certaines
choses aussi que je voudrais bien la
recherche des portes et des ports qu'à
tel endroit si le ver est ainsi venu
m'aider à rapporter pour les hommes se
connaissaient davantage de jours de
comptage le dimanche que pour des femmes
qui s'occupent eux de faire les courses
et on attend patiemment que les hommes
sont prêts à partir pour près de la
voiture
ça représente aussi le jour on a fait
des on en profite pour faire des
affaires les enfants sont libres on en
profite aussi pour faire des achats pour
eux on les emmène pour dans un chat au
surendettement
j'aimerais aussi sortir peut-être pas
tous les dimanches elle nous entends
jamais parce que il ya les bêtes ça
c'est une je crois que c'est une
souffrance pour pour moi femmes ont
aussi de pouvoir sortir comme comme
celle des villes
je voudrais bien me reposer un peu moi
je n'imagine pas je voudrais une chaise
longue
un bon vivre et voilà parce que je dois
tranquillité beaucoup plus c'est ce que
vous voudriez qu'est-ce que vous avez
battu travaille toujours avec les bêtes
on est obligé de toujours toujours
marché impute aux jours de visite au
toujours quelqu'un qui gagne alors on
peut pas se reposer sur tous les
dimanches moi je trouve que le dimanche
on devrait être assez libéré de tout
notre travail et pouvoir sont ils un
petit peu tanné que le plus souvent nous
restons amis
on se libère l'un ou l'autre veulent
notre famille ne travaille pas la
démarche soit je trouve que c'est très
intéressant et même pour pour la famille
pour les enfants et c'est formidable le
jour que on ne travaillait pas et bien
on se sent en alléger on est libéré de
ce poids a été commuée
dimanche c'était une autre voie de notre
soirée c'était pas notre associé c'était
notre vote d'examen l'an dernier nous
avons pu parti un peu les travaux d'été
nous avons pu partir trois jours la
mecque j'ai d'ailleurs beaucoup apprécié
puisque je souhaite qu'ils sont une
nouvelle fois on est allé à la bourboule
je me rappelle mon mari une journée une
autre fois installé on est allé à la mer
une autre fois
1 cité de carcassonne mais la sig avant
que la bourse aunès je ne suis pas allé
moi
mariette à elle seule est une autre vie
une autre foire au plumard ou quatre
fois toujours on a réussi pendant des
vacances une fois depuis qu'on est marié
depuis dix à quatre jours on doit y
arriver quand même envoyé à prendre
quelque chose par amazon com
la majorité n'est pas arrivé nous on
n'est pas arrivé
les essais killer qui les fait partir
vers la ville c'est sans doute se
respecte davantage de propreté qu'à la
campagne d'avoir un logement plus
agréable davantage de propreté dans les
maisons davantage de deux tenues plus
soignée chez la femme
vivre avec les parents c'est quelquefois
difficiles nous enfin moi j'y suis
habitué maintenant et non je me suis
pareil de mes beaux poèmes et fait
quelques fois je me dis ceci je suis a
commencé avec vérifier quelques balles
et je me même si je refusais pas
justement de livrer mes beaux-parents
quelques fois mais je clique pas moi
vous savez j'aime pas qu'on me mette
tous les torts sur les beaux-parents et
j'estime que c'est une question
d'indépendance et des foyers c'est pas
une question de belle-mère de bercy et
j'estime que chaque foyer a droit à
l'indépendance il faut des faits
pourrait faire de logements de la même
maison c'est mon avis franchement dans
la même maison que les préparatifs d'un
côté et les enfants de l'autre bord et
travailler ensemble mais pas habiter
ensemble parce que c'est surtout là dans
la vie de famille avec les enfants avec
ça et bien une petite bricole
quelquefois il ya des lecteurs quoi
parce que quand on entend des
conversations il y en a qui nous parlent
qu'aux toilettes qui ne parlent que des
sceaux est alors les sous des jeunes
filles d'aujourd'hui de notre taille
nous ne parlions pas toilettes comme ça
nous avions une robe quelque chose de
propre
bien sûr mais voilà aujourd'hui aisément
une semaine à laval une autre lune nous
arrive ça y est c'est la sortie no
aujourd'hui tout le monde les critiques
tout le monde dehors trouvera à redire
actuellement les jeunes filles veulent
d'avoir métier veulent pas d'avoir une
profession ne veulent pas rester là
attendant elles veulent pas voir
installèrent être indépendante
moi je me suis posé la question
plusieurs fois qu'est ce que parce que
fort les garçons quoi dans les am estime
même déjà parce que l'on envoie il y en
a ici je me suis pas le mans qui en 35mm
40 ans et qui sont là certainement notre
vous ne trouvez pas une jeune fille une
campagne c'est quand même urgent parce
qu'il ya des coins il ya des tas de gars
ont fait ce célibataire alors il ya une
cause il faut bien arriver à retenir les
filles campagnolo parce qu'il ya des
expressions qui sont viables et des
garçons est ce que deviendra campagne si
elle n'avait plus de s'il n'y avait plus
de femmes qui veulent rester à l'arrêt
ce moment là qu'il fallait les hommes
je crois que d'ici que ces fillettes de
2 km menant 12 13 ans prennent une
décision une évolution sera fait je
pense
elles sont allées la ville centre à
l'école et si elles choisissent vraiment
ne rester à terre elles voudront
toujours s'améliorer avoir des contacts
avec les autres moi je crois qu'elle
conduit en évolué
[Musique]